live local now good afternoon the first
lady landing in las vegas thanks for
joining us here at five o'clock i'm
denise feldas good evening i'm brian
loftis jill biden landed a short time
ago at mccarran airport
sasha loftis is there covering it live
for us right now sasha
brian and denise we were able to see the
first lady touchdown here at mccarran
about 30 minutes ago
just after 4 30 this afternoon now
governor steve sisolak was there to
greet her
along with several other local
dignitaries she is set to join service
employees international union members at
umc tomorrow
and meet local medical professionals for
national nurses day
here's a look at some video of when air
force two did touch down here on the
tarmac you can see governor sisilak and
nevada's first lady
going and speaking to first lady jill
biden
she just came from salt lake city where
she visited a middle school
thanking teachers for their dedication
during the pandemic
she also stopped at a pop-up vaccination
clinic in salt lake city
geared toward utah's hispanic community
she thanked volunteers there
and she will head to colorado springs
tomorrow afternoon
after her stop here in las vegas now
back out here live the first lady does
not have any public events scheduled
for after her arrival tonight again she
touched down just about a half an hour
ago
now you may encounter some traffic
delays over the next 30 minutes or so as
she does
go to her destination tonight where
she's staying so keep an eye on that
watch out for that motorcade we will of
course keep you posted here
on 8 news now on air and online
reporting live sasha loftis
8 news now